welcome my name is Auster and I'm an
engineer on the cloud sequel team in
this video I'll show you how to create
run and manage sequel instances using
Google Cloud sequel cloud sequel helps
manage mundane administrative tasks from
my sequel and Postgres databases so you
can focus on what matters let's walk
through how to create a my sequel
database on cloud sequel and connect to
it from the Google cloud shell you can
set up an instance in just a few steps
let's go through the basics and I'll
point out some options for additional
configuration along the way we'll start
by navigating to cloud sequel in the GCP
console and clicking create instance and
then next choose a second-generation
my sequel database engine
second-generation instances provide
better performance and improve
management tools like automatic storage
increase I'll name the instance and then
set the password for our default account
this instance will be created in the US
and we'll leave the zone set to any so
cloud sequel can choose for us let's
take a look at configuration options
you can specify my sequel version
instant size high availability and more
for this demo I'll choose a four core
high memory instance maximizing memory
is a good choice for my sequel because
it can take advantage of the extra
memory for performance that said don't
worry too much about initial sizing you
can scale the instance up or down later
let's increase the storage capacity to
200 gigabytes because increasing disk
capacity also increases performance
check out the performance calculator
below as I add capacity my disk
performance increases which will allow
my database to process more operations
per second and I'll enable automatic
storage increase so that I don't
accidentally run out of disk space
lastly let's ensure that the database
will automatically provide isolation
from failures we can do that by enabling
the high availability configuration
which for my sequel adds a fail over
replica in another zone now that we're
happy with the configuration of our
instance let's kick off the creation it
may take a few minutes for your instance
to create this is a great time to grab a
quick cup of coffee you can also check
the status of your instance by
navigating to your instance list once
you see a green check mark your instance
is ready
looks like our instance has finished
creating let's open the details page to
continue there are many ways to connect
to this instance within GCP for example
we could use App Engine compute engine
or container engine but we could also
connect from just about anywhere by
authorizing IP addresses or using the
cloud sequel proxy for this demo I'll
connect using the Google cloud shell
cloud shell provides command-line access
to all of your cloud resources such as
cloud sequel instances directly from the
browser to open the cloud shell click
connect using cloud shell as you can see
the relevant g-cloud command to connect
to your cloud sequel instance has been
pre typed for us so all we have to do is
press ENTER and then enter our root
password from before and now we're
connected so let's create and insert
some data to begin I'll create a
database next
insert some data
you
finally I'll make sure the data is now
in our database and it is great
so to recap in the last few minutes we
just created a cloud sequel instance
with high performance and high
availability and connected to it with
cloud shell now that you've seen how to
get started give it a try you can learn
more about Google Cloud sequel and our
free trial program here thank you for
watching